hey everyone good afternoon it's Mike
from order flows and you know if you
want to learn more about orderflow be
sure to like And subscribe this Channel
today I'll be talking about you know
recognizing Lowe's uh forming in the
order flow and how you can take
advantage of them and you know today in
the bonds
um you know there was an interesting uh
little sell-off then a rally and you
know just really quick you know if
you're on ninjatrader here's a nice
little free Ninja Trader hack they have
an actual indicator in ninjatrader 8 to
draw the low so you just scroll down you
open up the indicators and you scroll
down it's called the current open high
low close uh or current day OHL current
open high low we haven't closed yet so
it's just uh the current open high and
lows you just click on it make sure it
shows up in the configured and just
click apply and it'll draw
um a red line for the low a green line
for the high for the day and the it's
kind of like a yellow or Golden Rod
color for the opening price so you know
it's just a great way to have a
reference of where you're trading
relative to the higher the low of the
day as well as the open
um you know there's a reason why there's
a low of the days reason why is the high
of the day and anytime you're trading
around the high or the low you know you
want to be asking you know can we go
lower if we're at the low or can we go
higher if we're at the High
so you can see here let me just get the
crosshairs going on here so you know
this yellow line here 131 19 is the
opening price 20 is in the high since
the reopen and this yellow line you can
see this morning as we're coming down
making new lows now in the order flow
there's a few things I like to look for
when we're trading at the lows or at the
highs and I'll be talking about this as
we're coming into this low here
um
there's two in my opinion there were two
opportunities here in the morning to get
long okay the first one started going up
and then it petered out second one he
had this nice rally
um back up towards the high of the day
and
I have always talked about this you know
when I first released the order flows
Trader software in 2015
um you know two of the tools that we had
were tools that highlighted Divergence
and Order flows ratios now a Divergence
in the order flow is a new or equal high
or new equal low well first I'll start
with a bullish Divergence so it'd be a
new or equal low with positive Delta on
a green candle as you can see right here
right we have a new or equal low it's
equal here and we have positive Delta so
what that's telling you is buying came
into the market at the low that's a
potential opportunity to be getting long
now the opposite would be true at a high
a bearish order flow Delta Divergence
would be a new or equal high with
negative Delta and price action you know
a red candle indicating the market is
starting to potentially sell off now the
other part of it is the order flows
ratios right and you can see here this
blue number 0.14 you got another one
here 59.
now
these ratios you know what it reads is
it reads the order flow appearing in the
bottom of the bar of a green candle or
the top of a red bar and really what I'm
more interested in is not the actual
ratio itself because remember it's a
ratio it's not a number that's
calculated and then you come up with a
equation it's just a ratio it's reading
the ratio of the order flow towards the
bottom of a green candle or towards the
top and if it is blue
then it means you know that's within a
certain parameter that's indicating
either price defense or price rejection
if it's black right you see black here
12.77 2.35 13.4 2.9
um that's just your normal order flow
right markets exist to facilitate trade
to transfer risk from one party to
another so it's not uncommon
or actually it's more common rather and
I'll say uncommon it it's more common to
have regular order flow go through is
more common to have bars with regular
order flow going through nothing really
actionable but when I start seeing
you know bullish order flow in terms of
the ratios indicating price defense that
I got down here or Price exhaustion as I
have down here
um
that's actionable right tell me hey you
know what I'm at the low of the day I
have a Divergence and I have
price rejection coming in right I use
Price subject rejection and price
exhaustion kind of in the same
um vernacular
here I have price defense right I've got
a big bid down here 241 right I see
price defense coming in at this low
right you see came down hit 269 241 came
down tested it 122 made a new low
um
my one of my bread and butter trays that
I teach Traders is you know when you
have a Divergence and a ratio that's a
good sign that you know what this Market
potentially can start to take off this
is a bullish Divergence and you have
bullish order flow
but it didn't this one it just went up
about three ticks and then came right
back down made that new low you got
another signal here this is the trade
that had a nice move up now what's the
difference between these two right well
if you're looking at the order flow
remember it's not that you just have a
signal coming in like oh this is bullish
or this is bearish you still need that
follow through order flow to continue
right because remember it's not like you
just find you know you could go hide in
a cave and think I'm going to bring my
computer in there and I'm going to come
out you know figure out some way to
predict highs or lows it's not about
predicting Hydro lows it's about
following the order flow right because
if other Traders aren't buying after you
get long Mark is not going to go
anywhere right if instead as you have
here right Market starts to go up but
then the buying dries up and then the
strong selling comes in well you're
gonna you're gonna get stopped out right
what you want to see is
after you get long right you want to see
the positive order flow right the
continued buying coming in to move that
market higher
and there's several ways to determine
that in the order flow okay so while
having a ratio and Divergence
is good it's almost good enough you
still want to follow the order flow
after you get into the trade because
what's happening here in this red bar
down is you're starting to see some
strong Supply come into the market right
you see so say you get long off this bar
here right you got your ratio Divergence
off the low it's a good sign right I
like that okay now do bear in mind you
do have an unfinished auction here right
you got the 241 on the bid side the 299
which
you know if you trade unfinished
auctions you know that's a sign that
potentially the market could come back
and close that auction so you have that
sort of hanging over but again you know
that that's not written in stone that
the market has to come back markets
often do come back but
um you know that that's uh
I don't want you not taking a trade just
because there's an unfinished auction
there but you have to have that in the
back of your mind that you know what the
market could come back to that level but
what you're seeing in here right if
you're getting long right if you're long
off this bar here and and this is a bar
I like because you know Market's coming
down you have strong negative Delta then
weaker weaker than positive right so the
selling is kind of drying up it went
from -607 negative Delta to minus 114 to
minus 70 and then a positive right now
I've got positive Delta right I got that
Delta Divergence I've got a bullish
ratio
a market starts going up to one tick
higher two ticks higher than this bar
then three ticks higher but then it
starts selling off and as it sells off
you get big Supply coming into the
market 597 right this
um buying and balance here now some
people are going to say well isn't that
bullish right because it's a strong it
shows strong buying well in this case
it's actually bearish
and why is because the market is
starting to tick down and someone is
coming in here with Supply to absorb
whatever buying is taking place right
they have Supply to offer out to the
market all right Market starts trading
down that's your sign that you know what
we're probably going to come down and
close this auction right Market drops
down and eventually one bar later this
is a five minute chart we do close that
auction and you'd have been stopped out
but the sign was in here that Supply was
coming into the market not necessarily A
positive sign in the order flow right
it's not something that's convincing you
that hey you know what this Market could
go up what I would have liked to have
seen rather is this 597 instead of a
buying a balance I'd like to have seen a
selling and balance come in here you
know which would indicate that there's
supportive buying coming in okay but you
know this is what happened right the
supply came in Market you can see Market
made a new low
it traded down to 25 24 23 started to go
back up again more Supply coming in you
know 1015 on the offer here and you know
one of the obvious signs in the order
flow that Supply is coming into the
market is when you see
um strong the strongest volumes often
appearing on the offer side in red
candles right so I know that there's
still people that they've got some
Supply to offer out here the 1015 and
Market immediately drops back down to 24
so it comes back up it's sort of holding
this level right I mean first sign of
Supply came in at 130 101 second sign
came in at 131 even right so imagine
you're looking at this market like this
right in here
he saw some Supply come in here and it
sort of coming back up to that level you
still see more Supply coming in okay
what happens next Market drops down so I
know at 131 even there's some potential
Supply there because there just was I
saw it and even a tick higher at 01 so
you know this 131
um double O Let's draw a line here you
know to oh you know it's really o1 it's
double O and o1 but I'll draw that line
at O2 okay so I know that if I'm going
to come back up I got to get through
this area of Supply if it's still there
or if it's not there maybe the market
can just go higher so I know I've got
Supply right I know I've got resistance
at this area of double O and o1
okay so now I gotta watch you know
what's going on in the market
well we came back up we hit the double
o's
and then we drop back down to a new low
or sorry an equal low 130 23.
now the next bar now this work gets
interesting
because again we have that Divergence
and we have a bullish ratio
and we trade back up to that area that I
had sort of marked in here as resistance
based on Supply in the order flow
okay so I know I gotta get past this
double O I gotta get past this o one so
I really want to be trading on the other
side of o2 for this Market to you know
make a run back up towards these highs
up here or at least the opening price of
um 19.
so you know from basically O2 I've got a
Target up here of around you know 18 19
potentially
and you know what's my risk well again
this low I mean this is kind of a a
little bit bigger than I I like to see
but again this is a five minute chart
but it's shaping up as a potential long
right so just as I told you earlier that
I liked here I got the ratio and
Divergence here I got the ratio and
Divergence
but what's a little bit more interesting
in here now I don't have an unfinished
auction right a zero here okay and you
know over here I had that unfinished
auction which was sort of looming over
me
and another thing that I like is I like
as we come back down testing a low or
testing a high I like to see volume
decreasing dramatically 376. let me just
take off this uh low of the day
um line so it might be a little bit
easier to see because it might be a bit
hard to read those numbers with that on
there so let me just remove that and um
just give it a second here
move click apply
and you know the reason why I'm removing
that just for now just so it's a little
bit easier to read these numbers right
so you can see the 299 that unfinished
auction here so you see
even though you know it's 268 to 241 you
know it really wasn't that big of a drop
off but down here it was 376. and then
and then two so the first time you hit
that low is 376 traded Market went up
went up to resistance came back down it
traded 29 then over the next bar traded
two so where are my strong sellers
they're not there anymore right here you
had you know 268 the first time and then
241 you know there was interest in there
and even went
offered at that price you don't have any
unfinished auctions here so it's not
even going to offered and more
importantly
there's just not that interest that
there was earlier
okay so I have that going for it too
so what happens in the next bar boom we
finally trade above O2 right that area
of that resistance now there was 524
that traded here at Double O on the
offer we got past it right we got past
the 01 offer where there was that Supply
earlier right even up here you see the
the 272 traded on the offer now it's
just 127. so remember right what was
resistance if you get through it can now
be your support So now I've got my
bullish order flow coming in
all right with the ratio and the
Divergence and the declining volume
and now I'm above that resistance
you know I'm trading o6 so now this
resistance can potentially become
support and then what happens in the
next bar
we trade down into it down to o1 and
it's holding
next bar trade down o one double o
okay we're not trading through it your
resistance that this was your resistance
before is now becoming your support and
it's coming after the bullish order flow
is taking place
and then what happens Marcus starts just
stays above it points of control higher
this is your low so higher higher
they're both
aligned here two-pointed controls at the
same price level then another two bars
when it controls at the same price level
but they're higher higher right which is
what you want to see on a market that's
starting to move higher and then boom
another higher point of control
so the area to be getting long is in
here around the O2 area
right you're already seeing that sign of
the bullish order flow right let the
market get you in just drop a buy stop
in here at O2 because you're getting
past that resistance to get long so
you're
getting long up here at you know at O2
you know worst case scenario you know if
all hell breaks loose you know you have
a stop down here at 22.
um but ideally your Stop's going to be a
little bit tighter just below these
buying imbalance or just around these
buying imbalances or a just below
what was your resistance that's now your
support and then stack buying a balance
comes in so again you belong from O2
it's a quick move but 5 10 15 20 25
about 30 minutes all the way up to 12
right and you see it gets all the way up
to 18 doesn't quite hit 19 and 20 was
the high and then it sort of comes back
down you know back down to I know I've
got support down here at uh one and
double o
just sort of hangs around this o5 back
up to 12. now
there's an added way you can see it by
looking at the value area of the bars
right I know that
value area is a great way to see when a
market is balancing and more importantly
when a market is starting to move out of
balancing and in the order flows Trader
you could add the value areas onto your
bar so here I'll just add them on I'll
enable it because I have it disabled on
this chart but when I add it it's going
to tell me
or rather show me when a market is
balancing or when a market is starting
to move away from balancing and this is
where it gets interesting is because
when you have overlapping value areas
right as you have here right these Reds
are the bearish are the red candles with
their value area that's why it's called
red then the green candles this is the
value area this is the value area this
is the value area
is
when it's overlapping you can see this
value area overlaps previous bar
overlaps previous bar overlaps previous
bar overlaps previous bar overlaps
previous bar that's a sign that a market
is still balancing
so you know even if you're getting long
in here off this first low this first
ratio and Divergence you still have the
value is overlapping that's not exactly
the greatest sign that you want to see
on a market that's starting to move when
you come over here you got these four
bars with value areas overlapping but
between this bar here at 855 and the bar
at 9 you have a gap in the value
right which again that's bullish right
this is a way to see gaps
in the bars between bars all right so
all of a sudden you know you're forming
your value your balance area rather down
here between you know we'll call it 29
and 24 and all of a sudden we Gap out of
that area
what do you think that's going to be
right that's bullish and you can see
the market starts forming a new balance
area higher and this just starts going
higher the value areas start going
higher so you know that's
A Tale of Two lows right which one was
better well ideally this one is is
better I mean I I still this is I would
still
trade this one here but as soon as I see
the signs in the order flow coming in
like you see here with the supply
you know that's your sign that you know
this Mark this this is probably not
going to be moving okay
but this one here right you don't have
that you do know you do have that Supply
here
this area and I know that if I get
through it
it could be Off to the Races and we do
we just burst right through it and we go
higher okay and the clues obviously I
didn't even talk about you know this bar
with five buying imbalances in these
selling imbalances
um acting as support but you got the
aggressive buying coming in you Gap up
in the value you close well above your
previous resistance area which has now
turned into support and the market is
going higher so you know that's how you
can put the pieces of order flow
together so I hope you enjoyed this
video you know and found it useful again
you'll be sure to like And subscribe the
channel
and
I'll talk to you guys soon bye-bye